Sully was directed by Clint Eastwood and
it stars Tom Hanks don't worry I'm not
gonna do that anymore
this is the true story of The Miracle on
the Hudson a pilot who landed an
airplane on the Hudson River when his
engines failed it's a retelling of that
event as well as the aftermath of it
when people started to doubt whether or
not he actually could have made it to
the runway did he endanger these
people's lives by landing on the Hudson
River or could he have made it back to
the airport the public and media
scrutiny that develops around this man
as well as how he deals with it in his
personal life I was looking forward to
this movie because I mean it's a Clint
Eastwood directed movie starring Tom
Hanks any time Tom Hanks is in a movie I
want to see it because he is one of the
best working actors ever
he's been around my entire life my
entire life has been Tom Hanks he's
awesome I mean if you don't at least
slightly appreciate Tom Hanks as an
actor I really don't understand that
Eastwood as an actor I love and
basically everything as a director he
has hits and misses he likes to make
very desaturated movies that look very
blue or very gray and sometimes they can
get a little over long and the pacing
can drag I think he actually may have
realized that because Sully is one of
his shortest films and I like this movie
Tom Hanks was excellent and it's kind of
a cliche to say that I mean Tom Hanks
was really good in this movie guys Wow
Nick's fat what a shock I mean I said it
he's one of the greatest working actors
when you go into a movie with Tom Hanks
in the role you know that you're at
least gonna get a good performance but
he is great in this film very subdued
nothing about his performance shouts
look at me I'm an actor give me an Oscar
right now he's the kind of actor that is
so famous that he can kind of sit back
and be almost minimalistic in his
performance and it still works
Aaron Eckhart was also a great presence
as the co-pilot who was there on this
day I really liked him in this movie
also Anna Gunn from Breaking Bad she
finally gets to really sink her teeth
into a big Hollywood movie and I thought
she did a really good job in this film
the movie opened in a way that I didn't
expect it actually opens with the event
having already happened and now we're in
the meat of it we're already seeing him
with the media and public
and we're trying to figure out what's
going on you would think a little more
suspense would be built up in a movie
like this but at first it was a little
jarring like oh we're just we're in it
now okay and I was getting into it and
it was sort of almost like very
procedural and I liked that I liked
going through the facts and figuring out
what was going on on this day I liked
the fact that the movie wasn't just like
here's Sully he's a hero it was like no
look at all these various things that
could have happened and this gives you a
little more doubt and it makes the story
more interesting and more compelling the
issue for me came at the end of the
first act we get our first flashback
sequence where we do actually go back
and see the events that took place on
that day and for me to call it a
flashback I think is poor word usage on
my part because it's like a 15 minute
sequence and then we go back to the
present and we go back to the past again
and we see things way in the past like
when he was first discovering his love
of aviation and it just didn't form a
perfect whole for me the minute you're
getting into one time period you go back
to the past the minute you're getting
into that you go back to the present and
I personally think this film would have
been far more compelling if it just told
it in chronological order the film
wisely understands that it needs to
build up Sully as a character and not
just rely on our knowledge of the news
so we get sequences where he's calling
it home to his wife and children his
wife who's played by Laura Linney and
she doesn't really get to do much of
anything except walk around a house and
talk on the phone the film needs to show
that side of his life because it's
important to understand that he's a
married person but it just doesn't
really add up to anything beyond we need
to show this because he is married and
we have to have it in the film these are
issues that come with true stories being
adapted to film because a film will try
to be very theatrical and try to tell a
story that's all very nice and sometimes
in real life you don't get those moments
and it doesn't always translate to film
perfectly so I can't really downgrade
the film for that just because Laura
Linney's character doesn't have a big
arc or because of things like that
because if that's really how it was then
that's how it was and that's fine my
biggest issue with the storytelling is
simply jumping all over time periods I
think if it had been in chronological
order as I said it would have been more
compelling but nevertheless because of
Tom Hanks and Aaron Eckhart in this film
and Anna Gunn in particular I think
these performances really worked also
towards the latter half of the movie
when they're doing the hearings about
whether and
he could have done something else I was
feeling very very into it and the film
does have a good feeling of suspense and
for all those reasons I enjoyed Sully
overall and I'm gonna give it a B I
recommend seeing this I don't think you
have to rush out and see it I think it's
a very good movie with good performances
but I do think it could have been great
also stay tuned this Sunday because I'm
gonna be continuing my Harry Potter
series of reviews leading up to
fantastic beasts and where to find them
Harry Potter and the Prisoner of Azkaban
that's gonna be this Sunday speaking of
Harry Potter look at that amazing figure
behind me I love it it's an incredible
Harry Potter figure I want to thank the
big bad toy store one of the best online
toy stores I got that toy from them I
left a link for their store it's a
custom link that you can go through me
and visit their store so much awesome
stuff and very good prices as well I
pre-order all my hot toys from them to
look forward to Prisoner of Azkaban on
Sunday thank you so much as always for
watching and if you liked this you can
click right here and get stuff mine eyes
[Applause]
[Music]